[Music]
did you guys hear
about the whole spotify drama with joe
rogan on his podcast saw a glimpse of it
and i'm like what the [ __ ] wait
wait a way don't worry let me [ __ ]
put my hair up for the show oh yeah me
too [ __ ] put it on for this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
tell me the cheese mess let me tell you
so spotify employees are demanding
direct editorial oversights over
the recently acquired joe rogan
experience podcast
and they're saying that they would like
to have the ability to directly edit or
remove sections
of upcoming interviews or block the
uploading of episodes deemed problematic
and also
to add trigger warnings corrections and
reference
references to fact-checked articles on
topics discussed by joe rogan
jesus and so the this group
they're they're being very demanding
they're saying that and then also
they're like if they don't they're going
to go on strike or something right
forgot the most important
wait so workers within the spotify
company
is asking to censor joe rogan
and is it because they're threatening
with going on strike and is it
is it because of the uh the fire
mistake that he did so joe rogan
recently made a mistake
saying that um people were committing
arson
and the forests uh but he was going
based off of
one confirmed incident where a person
did commit arson
in california or oregon it's not based
off one specific episode it's actually a
lot
over so i think the controversy that
people
or like why the people that back joe
rogan are mad
is that it's just what he represents
so these people are trying to censor
which is also like a strike against the
first amendment
and they're threatening to go on strike
if they can't control
pretty much what facebook is doing with
people's posts that's what these people
in spotify are trying to do on spotify
wow
okay i get it if they want to
fact check and edit certain things but
if they're
trying to be biased because of it goes
against their own political opinion
how can you not be biased well you can
be not biased because
let's say he has a fact incorrect like
such as the um the arson thing the arson
thing right
he he could have just said like oh uh
you know i
uh people in california are committing
arson like that could be incorrect right
but um they can fact check that and go
oh wait no
that wasn't that was in california that
was oregon and they can correct that or
they can edit that out well
the whole editing thing is um
it seems to be kind of like a slippery
slope situation sort of thing because
they're saying like
the reason why joe rogan went over to
spotify
it's just it's just a licensing deal
like there is no
creative control over the show so then
having
having the authority to edit the show
now is
crossing a very very strict line right
because
spotify doesn't own the content it's not
a
um it's not like a like a like a
production house you want to re-release
it
exactly yeah it's like netflix which is
yeah so
spotify has already said that they have
they have already removed certain
episodes that had pro
problematic guests so like
for example they had they removed
episodes with interviews with
uh alex jones and gavin mckinnon's
and some other people and so they're
so that means like spotify has already
somewhat compromised with their
employees to be like okay so these are
these are really problematic episodes
okay we won't air these but then the
spotify employees are saying
so we want creative control over the
entire podcast and if you don't we're
walking out
but that's what happens when you get 100
million right
no that's what happens when you go to a
company
that has a lot of different um well
for one i think their silicon valley or
or
in that area well this article reported
that spotify employees reportedly earn
on average anywhere from 120 to 130 000
a year
with considerable perks and benefits as
well so then they're just like this one
particular particular article is like
why the [ __ ] are they complaining is
this the only way
you can listen to the joe rogan podcast
now because now they're exclusive to
spotify oh they're exclusive to spa
doesn't he post them on youtube though
for now but eventually it's supposed to
be
all just solely on spotify that's the
whole licensing deal well then that just
sounds like it's becoming a breach of
contract and that might
might be uh he might be able to get out
of it then
because it's like if the contract stays
i don't know if he wants to get out of
it
he has 100 million at stake yeah but i
mean i guess
then i think that's not the same i think
the thing isn't about the contract the
thing is about
the whole censorship aspect of this
right i think it's
it's uh what peop what's i guess up for
debate
is are these employees are they even
allowed to do that yeah
not so much what joe rogan's content is
but should people yeah i guess should
people at spotify should people at
facebook
people that twitter should people at
youtube at any platform should they be
allowed to edit
the content creators content yeah yeah
yeah i get that but i guess i'm bringing
in the contract specifically because i'm
saying
he doesn't have to fall into that if he
doesn't want to
you know like it sucks that that that's
happening with spotify and it's
kind of happening everywhere but i think
when these bigger creators can stand up
for it and be like yo
this is censorship i'm not for it take
your money back
which is a [ __ ] big-ass bag and it's
like ominous
but then i think i think they i think
someone has to set the example you know
what i mean where it's like
hey [ __ ] keep your money i want to
keep saying what the [ __ ] i want to say
i want to talk to the people who are
against this
and dissect every single in like example
of what they feel should be censored or
not because sometimes it might be
reasonable
sometimes it might be hey dude you just
have one way of thinking and you're
trying to control everyone's world
back in july there was this joe rogan
podcast where he interviewed abigail
schreier which is
she's the author of the book
irreversible damage the transgender
craze seducing our daughters and
and during her entire interview she was
talking about how
the transgender youth uh with um
they end up pressuring other young
people
to transition and like she was just
making all these outrageous claims and
and so the fact that joe rogan gave her
a platform
and didn't really dispute much of what
she was saying
people are calling him transphobic now
and saying like but his whole
format is letting people be themselves
not convincing them
of his ideas of moral right or wrong
totally
and but i feel like the spotify
employees here they're feeling like
they if you're gonna be giving the
platform like such a huge platform for
people that are damaging like they have
crazy ideas that could damage society in
whatever way then that that's
irresponsible
so that's kind of what they're claiming
i think that
if you are an intelligent person
you pick and choose what you want to
believe and listen to
i love the fact that we have this
uncontrolled
like as number one podcaster where you
can listen to
any opinion and it's so diverse in
thought
and whatever and you get to kind of
explore the minds and how cultures are
created and how people
can think a certain way and to me i like
i [ __ ] love that because it gives me
an inside look into how people come
up with these conclusions even if
they're transphobic
it's not that i back it up but i'm like
now i can see how this thought process
evolved in this person's mind and why a
set of
people within our country think a
certain way and then you can go ahead
and go
now i because i understand that thought
process maybe i can have a conversation
with them
and if i don't believe what they believe
i can also
with empathy now be able to at least
see if they can open up the door and
listen to me because now i can
you know instead of two people going
back and forth like you're just [ __ ]
wrong
and i don't even know why you think the
way that you do but you're wrong because
you don't believe what i believe
yeah i think it's like you know some
people will say that
you shouldn't give like problematic
people a platform but i feel like
it's not you gotta let people how would
you know you disagree with them if you
never heard what they have to say
right and like you need to explore yeah
i also think if it's your platform it's
your platform you know i mean if it's
your platform you have
every right to do with what you want
with your not necessarily because for
example with
with alex jones spotify removed
his podcast from the platform for hate
content
so like they're they're they are
censoring some people or whatever and so
that's why i
they ended up removing that interview
with joe rogan with alex jones as well
because he's just a problematic person
all around
and i agree with what you guys are
saying where people should be hearing
different sides definitely but then i
think that's
how we end up getting into the situation
like with facebook
how information is spread like wildfire
and no one ever fact checks and then
it actually ends up affecting the
elections or whatever it is and that's a
that's a dangerous
route if it's not if it's not being
handled in any certain way but i also
think it's dangerous
to give people power to control that
that is also dangerous
i agree first of all right what if the
censorship committee
committee was controlled by um the
christian right
that's not fair for other people who
don't believe in the same type of
ideas of what they think is moral or
ethical right
so if they are the ones that are part of
the fcc or the censorship
group and they believe that this is
what's moral
and um you know you can't have any talks
about gay or
or abortion or anything like that
because to them that's wrong
right so now you have a group like let's
say um
you know right now silicon valley is
heavily left
and although i might not agree with all
these other crazy dudes that are in the
far right or whatever
i feel that because it's controlled by
the far left
in a lot of media or whatever they feel
that it's their moral right
to shape society a certain way and if
they hear
any christian rhetoric or anything like
that they go
that's wrong that shouldn't be on our
platform or whatever
and to me that's that's why it's kind of
like whoever's the gatekeeper
if they're personally putting their own
ideas of how
society should be i think that goes
against being american
because what it should be is that
everyone here
as long as you're not breaking any laws
you can speak your mind of how you think
culture should be shaped or laws or
whatever you speak your mind
and then you get judged for your
opinions in but you should at least be
able to speak them
what's happening here is they're being
silenced and i'm like
hey if they're saying some crazy [ __ ]
right
i don't know what they're saying but i'm
just i'm just thinking yeah if they're
saying extremely crazy [ __ ]
maybe but but then it's extreme to whom
you're right yeah yeah that's true
like tiff said it's a slippery slope and
that's why for me i'm like
everyone's gonna have their biases and i
think you need to just align yourself
with the company or the representation
that aligns with yours
and that's what i'm saying like with
what's happening now it sounds like it's
going to become a breach of contract
so it would be in his best interest if
he cares about the authenticity of his
brand
uh to just kind of pull back away from
that and find something that alliance
better i mean the bag might be different
you know what if okay so for example
right like
let's say um all the media companies
are basically owned by uh liberal
leaning
um um like like owners right
i think it's only fox or new york post
or just
one of the companies is like republican
so if that let's say this company goes
down
and all of the news networks and
everyone is leaning left
then if you have republican values or
even
like libertarian or green party or
whatever and if it doesn't fit
with the liberal mindset you're getting
discriminated against because now you
don't have a platform
so if spotify and all these other major
platforms
lean only one way then we don't really
have diversity
we have just one party controlling
everything
yeah you do but then look at how it
started right like he started on a
podcast that's completely independent
yeah so i feel like there's always at
least
history for now has has shown that like
when there's a will there's a way right
there's like so many new platforms
popping up and there's
he already has an audience so it's like
just kind of moving your audience to
kind of go where you need to go because
there's obviously a demand like he has
he's so popular for a reason so there's
there's this hunger in this thirst for
the content that he's producing so i
think
if he were to leave i i feel like a lot
of people would follow him yeah like how
howard stern is
like the only dude that keeps exam alive
i mean at the end of the day right if i
let's say spotify
bought no chaser and they were like 100
million dollars 100 million even 50
million and they were like hey man
we gotta we gotta take off these
episodes in these episodes i'm like
all right i'm like i already put that
[ __ ] out you're like cool
i don't give a [ __ ] about tacos anyway
i'm like i already bought you people
with them with them dictating which
guests you have on what you can say
no getting really well then yeah you
can't control that
but then okay yeah okay what if they're
like we don't like david they keep they
keep
going like inch by inch they keep
infiltrating little by little i mean but
that's what contracts are for right
you would think 100 million then some
strings are going to come attached
i think it also depends on what you
stand for right because joe rogan's
whole content is going onto the platform
and and just discussions and letting
people be who they are and like listen
to them and like
figure it out it goes against that so
for you
send foods like even if they i don't
like this restaurant it doesn't go
against
who you are as tim so i think that's
that's the difference
it's one is going against i think
integrity
versus the other one is like ah we just
don't want you to do tacos anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you